oggi ragazzi scrive una nuova pagina del
canale ma proprio della serie questo qua
è un gioco
quindi non dimenticherete mai questo è
il primo episodio di totali a kuwait
battel simulator
non so se vi ricordate ragazzi tutte le
cure di battere grams che era un gioco
che avevo fatto con il signor gatto ecco
molto molto bene hanno fatto gli stessi
creatori dico giovani hanno fatto anche
totali a kuwait battersi un altro che
cos'è semplicemente ragazzi ci sono due
squadre ok è un orango tango e piccoli
serpenti
tu devi semplicemente vincere la
battaglia schierando le tue truppe
insomma in questo caso tipo io posso
schierare le stesse che ci sono di qua e
bisognava e bisogna utilizzare un tot di
punti per perché ovviamente più punti ai
più robe puoi schierare ma voi non avete
idea della bellezza dei combattimenti di
sta roba questo è il primo livello per
farvi capire un attimino cioè proprio
loro e proprio avengers infinity ward va
bene e a parte questi qua che non hanno
una spina dorsale e si menano che tra
l'altro stravinto io gli ho fatto un
culo male non so scrivere ste techno a
parte questo si è preso una cravatta nel
muso però ho vinto io sono stato
veramente bravo pare non essere un gioco
di culo tattiche e perché ad esempio qua
ci sono dei t days tira lance ok che
sono dieci io ne posso schierare al
massimo 6 56 quindi già quadro si
schierò questi che sono di meno di
quelli degli avversari
secondo me ma e questi sono rimasti
senza anche che sia il mio e fauna non
si doveva fare così proviamo un'altra un
altro approccio ragazzi bravi ragazzi
l'approccio del dei protettori ok
nell'uso bocca il kaki non solo 4 e poi
mettiamo due lancieri dietro 44 lance e
4 protettori proviamoci voi con la
lancia non colpiti così coppa bravissimo
sta funzionando
mi manca solo che fa che fanno
eva best action qualche roba non sanno
più ragazzi loro loro tentano e si dice
a grano ok agli altri colpiscono quindi
perfetto che tattica ha funzionato
mi spiace mira già privati mtr playlist
ratio ti prego perfetto ai ragazzi la
tattica prevede e funziona cioè bisogna
bisogna che studiare cioè non è l'europa
è utile mago delle ossa che non so che
cacchio si sa cos'è che adesso ce
l'hanno loro rocce giganti e scettri qua
sono nella cacca piena cosa va la barba
go delle non solo la faccia il mago
delle ossa li metto tutti i marchi delle
ova solo perché voglio vedere cosa fanno
cioè non lo so questa roba
un santo iddio le immagini e le ossa
quanto pare fanno un attacco ad area
ok dove colpiscono delle persone è molto
forte il mago delle ossa quindi io uteri
utilizzerei 2 lancieri anzi quattro
lancieri quatre protettori sul mago
delle ossa e poi le metterei nome ne
mettiamo in atto mentre altri tira lance
ok che arrivano però di qua 23 ok
perfetto si tira avanti e si occupano
dei maghi della strada lontano vediamo
se funziona il ragazzo ne sono sicuro
perfetto perfetto ha funzionato ragazzi
ma solo uno stratega sono uno stratega
nato sforzano già fortissimo ma voleva
che strage gli abbiamo fatto un culo
male siamo fortissimi mago fa la cosa a
perfetto si è immolato è morto anche lui
però vabbè appoggiare solo fortino
ragazzi sono fortissimo e la madonna non
vedo l'ora di sbloccare il bambù no
ragazzi ma è bellissimo è un gioco
bellissimo fermi c'è veramente per gioco
della madonna
ditemi quello che volete ma ti sto gioco
è fantastico
voglio usare vorrei usare un mammut per
vedere cosa succede a secondo me quasi
usa un buggy dell'osso ha vinto perché
questi sono tutti tizi con uno scudo e
io li devo far fuori da sotto e per
farli fuori da sotto
i maghi delle cose dagli usa rischiano
così come ho già vinto però vediamo che
succede ragazzi possesso ai unica posso
utilizzare una comunità madonna che
casino hanno fatto i ragazzi però dovete
ricaricare veloci ricaricate perché vi
diate sassate tanto hanno un mondo di
guerra fantastico paolo una roba del
genere bellissimo posso impossessarmi di
un'unità quanto pare alla cambia anche
la mappa change my mind è fantastico sto
cacchio di gioco e bellissimo cos'è sta
roba
sono gli smoking quelli coi forconi va
bene allora io utilizzerei dei lancieri
di qua che stanno da questa parte ed i
lancieri che stando a quest'altra e fin
qua ok vediamo l'attimo set di
impossessarmi di unità non so come a
vedi io posso combattere e bellissimo ok
sono morto ma ne è valsa la pena ragazza
porcaccia bach
mi sembra un po un esagerazione ma
mentre quali si ricaricano gli altri ti
prendono una mazzata per un perfetto
ragazzi sono fortissimo
non mi va di impostare un personaggio
perché mi sento molto più scarso posso
usare il mammut lega può susa voglio
solo vedere come vediamo un attimo mi
sembra un pelo un'esagerazione però va
bene è fortissimo era stato solo questo
è fortissimo e onora il gioco dell'anno
fermi c'era una nuova spaventapasseri
cos'è fermi non lo so cos'è così sta
roba spaventapasseri è fortissimo ma e
ci sono sono diversi enel conta di
personcina raccoglitore venditori di
pozzo di balla di fieno lo
spaventapasseri lancia dei passeri vabbè
c'è poco da fare progetti dovrebbe
spaventare i fas e in una ciascuno e
muoio erano un po troppi effettivamente
a fronteggiare prova beh non mi
interessano spaventapasseri ma
raccoglitori si tra i raccoglitori
vediamo cosa fanno così qua madonna
regata falce pazzesca ragazzi colpite
bravi così che ancora ancora una volta
una volta tutti aderito perfette vinta
l'inter inter sono fortissimi
ho dovuto uccidere un mio compagno che
non l'ha presa bene non l'ha presa bene
ma prego i cavalieri con gli arcieri un
po tutto ragazzi allora mettiamo due
arcieri qua è veramente un casino raga
cioè sta roba
anzi di più facciamone 45 55 arcieri un
miliardo di scudieri ma servono solo per
distrarre i minotauri e gli arcieri
fanno tutto il lavoro sporco da lontano
e minotauri sono occupati non sono
preoccupati perché vedo che hanno ucciso
tutti arcieri veloci i minotauri anno fu
accusato gli arcieri hanno fatto solo
bene
per ora il buon casinò è perché adesso
c'è un cavaliere dei soul due cavalieri
dei soldati sono vere il suo difficile
primio tauri e poi non so quanto duro
minotauro
mica minotauro e guarda che roba
c'è il fortissimo troppo brava papà
perfetto l'ex sound effect del minotauro
un minotauro contro un cavaliere i due
soldati è un casino ma ce la dovremo
fare attenzione
e ancora vivo ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto
io scritto io l'ha fatto fuori lui
bravissimo quindi ragazzi
questo era totali al tour eight bartel
grounds questa la prima vittoria l'ho
fatto con la campagna la prima la prima
fase della campagna per ora è bellissima
rosie episodi ragazzi prova a farlo
online perché suo gioco è anche online e
vediamo cosa succede ragazzi
meraviglioso questi ragazzi di le più
sicure c'è un punto è un mi piace anche
avere i social minuto con descrizione se
non se dovessi di schiena come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]